My name is Ho, Chien-Kuan, and I am a new
fellow of the Harvard Berkman Klein Center.
I have been a prosecutor for about two or
three years in Taiwan.
This year my research will primarily focus
on how to more effectively investigate cyber
crime.
With the development of technology, many criminals
may use new cyber tools to commit a crime,
such as mobile malware, and ATM fraud, et
cetera.
The growth of cybercrime remains a great threat
to security in our world.
Therefore, law enforcement authorities have
to improve their capability to investigate
cybercrime more effectively.
With the massive use of the technology of
the Internet, everyone could be a potential
victim of this technology.
In our world, the reality is that everyone
who is connected to the Internet is vulnerable
to cyber attack.
It's not only big companies that are under
threat.
Individuals who don't think they have much
to offer the hackers can be also targeted.
So even if you don't think you are a big target,
you should still care for this risk.
Modern technology is certainly fascinating.
Social networks have allowed us to share almost
anything, anytime, anywhere.
Smartphones and the Internet have dramatically
changed the way we communicate.
But criminals may also use these technologies
to commit crimes.
What scares me the most about technology is
the increasing misuse of anonymity and encryption
services on the Internet has become a critical
impediment of the investigation and the prosecution
of criminals.
If law enforcement cannot keep up with the
progress of technology, our world may become
a paradise for criminals.